you feel that that films for  african-americans are a little too  formulaic  yeah that's starting to bother you yeah  I mean you know well I mean they they're  all the they all kind of have the same  things in it no matter what cone and  it's gonna end in a family Union I don't  care I don't care what the movie is this  is every activity if you look at the  extended cut of the equalizer yeah after  he killed off everybody they had a big  family and they did Electric Slide you  can just put in I'll just think about it  like if you change any movie like if you  had the Goodfellas all black ass yeah  murder murder  you know mayhem mayhem family taken  taken the daughter gets taken right and  it's still a family I have a very  special set of skills  I know these versions of these movies  would be a lot more fun  you